>> HILLARY CLINTON JUST WON'T GO
AWAY.
STAFFERS AT "VANITY FAIR" HAVE
SUGGESTIONS TO KEEP HER BUSY AND
OUT OF POLITICS.
>> TIME TO START WORKING ON YOUR
SEQUEL TO YOUR BOOK.
WHAT THE HELL HAPPENED?
>> DISABLE AUTO-FILL ON YOUR
NEW YEAR.
VOLUNTEER WORK.
KNITTING.
COMEDY, ANYTHING TO KEEP YOU
VODOO DOLL.
>> CHEERS TO YOU, HILLARY
CLINTON.
>> LITERALLY ANYTHING.
THOSE TIPS DID NOT GO OVER WELL
WITH HER SUPPORTERS.
THERE IS A BACK LASH ON SOCIAL
MEDIA OVER THE VIDEO CALLING IT
SEXIST TO SUGGEST THAT HILLARY
CLINTON TAKE UP A HOBBY BY
KNITTING.
THEY DID SNARKY NEW YEAR'S
RESOLUTIONS FOR A BUNCH OF
POLITICIANS.
IT WAS AN ATTEMPT AT HUMOR AND
REGRET IT MISSED THE MARK.
TOM, OUR RESIDENT KNITTER.
>> I GUESS KNITTING IS
ASSOCIATED WITH WOMEN.
THEY SUGGESTED SHE TAKE UP
COMEDY.
AN ART FORM ASSOCIATED WITH MEN.
>> YOU ARE NOT HELPING.
>> [LAUGHING]
>> I SAID YESTERDAY ON THIS
THE DEMOCRATS ARE CHANTING THAT
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON.
THEY WANT HER TO GO AWAY.
DID YOU SEE THOSE PEOPLE.
>> THESE ARE MILLENNIALS.
THIS IS A CHANGING OF THE MEDIA
GUARDS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE SAYING PLEASE
DON'T RUN AGAIN BECAUSE YOU ARE
TANKING THE PARTY.
HILLARY CLINTON IS SO DESPERATE
AWAY AND REEXAMINE HER LIFE.
AFTER A YEAR OF MAKING FUN OF
HER, SHE IS SUCH A GREAT TIME.
I HOPE SHE DOESN'T GO ANYWHERE
AND RUNS FOR PRESIDENT IN 2018.
SHE PROVIDES MATERIAL.
STAY IN THE LIMELIGHT.
YOU ARE A BLAST!
IT'S AN ENDLESS SUPPLY OF JOKES
AND BARB.
STICK WITH IT.
>> THE SADDEST PART OF THE STORY
IS "VANITY FAIR" SOMEWHAT
THAT PEOPLE ON THE INTERNET ERA
ARE ABLE TO KEEP FOR THEMSELVES.
IT'S A CONTROL 72 DEGREES.
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> EVERYTHING AFIRMS YOUR WORLD
VIEW.
YOU ONLY HEAR YOU ARE RIGHT.
WE SHOULD POINT OUT, THE MOST
DISASTROUS NATIONAL POLITICIAN,
TWO PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS, LOST
TO THE TWO MOST UNLIKELY.
LOST TWICE.
ONCE TO A GUY WHOSE MIDDLE NAME
WAS HUSSEIN.
SHE IS THE WORST DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE SINCE AT LEAST DUKAKIS.
>> SHE BEAT RICK LASIO.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
HERE IS THIS PERSON.
A TARGET ARE RIDICULE.
GENTLE MOCKING.
THE FACT THAT THAT IS TOO MUCH.
YOU CAN'T TAKE THIS MOCKING AND
IT HAS TO BE DISSECTED ON THE
BASIS OF SEXISM.
>> IF YOU DO SOMETHING WRONG OR
SOMEONE CALLS YOU ON SOMETHING,
THAT PERSON IS NOT AUTOMATICALLY
RACIST OR SEXIST.
>> RIGHT.
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON ON
TELEVISION AGAIN.
IT'S FRUSTRATING.
AND ALSO BECAUSE SHE IS NOT THE
FUTURE OF THE PARTY.
REPUBLICANS LOVE MAKING FUN OF
HER.
>> AND DEMOCRATS.
BE IN FOR A BIG SURPRISE COME
NOVEMBER.
THERE AREA LOT OF NEW DEMOCRATS
WHO ARE NOT HILLARY CLINTON
DEMOCRATS.
WE ARE ABOUT TO TURN A PAGE INTO
A BIG ELECTION THAT IS NOT ABOUT
THE CLINTONS.
>> HOPEFULLY THERE WILL BE NEW